welcome back
to our sibling show which we've
established is so meaningful fun and
just wonderful
and these siblings have never been on a
television show
together
david sedaris is my favorite writer on
planet earth period he's
he's
he's made my life better he's also the
first person who brought holiday and
humor together for me i was so miserable
on the holidays and he just made me
realize i didn't have to be anymore
and also as an actor and a comedian
myself there's no one i admire more than
amy sedaris she's
these are national treasures and they're
going to be on a talk show for the very
first time together it is my esteemed
honor
to bring out here amy and david sedaris
[Music]
i'm so relieved that you're back
because
i
the first time you came on this show
at one point i was screaming
and then you cried four times
four times well i
would love to ask you both uh all the
neighborhood kids that you grew up with
wanted to come to your house and play
with you and your sisters they wanted to
be in your productions so to speak yeah
and you guys kind of
like stayed amongst yourselves
like it was elite you wouldn't let
people in so much no we just didn't need
them
no i mean there were six kids in the
family so we don't really need
other
people and if you're gonna well you know
you don't right
i love the way that you guys
speak about each other like
you talk about like the love of one of
his books being released or
the way that you speak about him that
i've read
is just it's so loving and ad admiring
um
will you look at your brother and tell
him what you admire or and love about
him you never do that oh my god we buy
each other's gifts so we don't have to
say it yeah we would never ever we
that's one thing like when sometimes i
hear people on the phone i love you i
love you i've never i've i don't think
i've ever said that maybe now is the
time
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my goodness
no we
we show it
with
yeah i mean i think the best times that
we share
are just shopping that's really all we
care about but sometimes i'll overhear
him talking to the lady at the cash
register and he's telling her that he's
a doctor that he operates on children's
eyes and that he removes the eyeball and
replaces them with buttons and i'm like
we gotta go dave okay okay yeah why do
you happen to overhear it why do you do
that because my initials are dr and they
say well dr sedaris and then i just i
don't know i you just go with i always
wanted to be a doctor and then i think
yeah what kind of a doctor are you i
operate on children's
eyes
that just came to me
i mean
i wanna make sure that i hit your new
book a carnival of snackery which is
your diaries i mean i've read everything
that you've ever written multiple times
and i was just enjoying this so much and
i wanted to ask because i i
i
i have a really sick sense of humor
and yet i tread light in life you know
like i'm so worried to
rock someone's boat or offend or upset
them
how
do you put it all out there like you do
i just love it
but i mean i'm not a mean person no but
i mean now but you're brave but now
people get angry if you think something
right like if you think but you can't
tell me that every like it's let's say
if somebody is i don't know it's
starbucks right
and then they're ordering a liquid candy
bar right and then
you know like one of those complicated
drinks and then they this they want to
pay this way and then they change their
mind and they want to pay this way and
then their phone rings they get on the
phone
you can't convince me that everyone in
that line doesn't wish there was a
trapdoor
[Music]
[Applause]
so
and then it would it would drop down
like 20 feet and there would be spikes
like this
but but to think it i see nothing wrong
with thinking it to say to that person
you need to die
i wouldn't do that and i wouldn't like
the person who would say that but right
it's fine to think
god bless you for it the fun part at
least you can right just to fantasize
about ways people can die
our amazing co-hosts have a question um
for you would you please take it away
alice and alicia you and amy were to
ever write a book together what would
you call it yeah
i did all the work
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if you were to write a book about david
what would it be called it'd be i hope
you like short stories it would be short
pamphlet size it would be a scrambler
you know we have to find the word
and then what would that word be gay gay
gay gay so it'd be like a 5.
i want to live life with you
[Music]